[Music]  in shock therapy news  oh no premature ejaculation could be  cured with a new stick on patch for your  taint oh my god  why just [ __ ] boss wait is this  supposed to make you calm or prevent me  vent you from consensus like really  please yeah how does it stay on because  that area pretty loose loose why that  ball skin no it's your yeah that area is  connected to the ball skin tight your  glutes like it's like this it's like  this you were supposed to cut that off  when you're a baby I think you have  taint jowl you're both sexes very tight  very tight is it is it the book yeah so  you have to go I can't sit on a  medically worried about you cuz you're  my father well tell luckily for you this  is a patreon video